you don't own your games anymore or your
movies and that's a bad thing or your
music that's right it's time for a video
game preservation episode of spot on all
your TV shows let's talk about it
here on spot on we like to talk about
the issues in gaming uh right now and I
think one of the biggest issues that
kind of crops up occasionally but should
be at the front of people's minds a lot
more is that of video game preservation
so Tam why are we talking about it
specifically this week uh we are talking
about this this week because it's at the
tip of everyone's tongue it's the the
kind of like major conversation right
now and this week also the video game
history Foundation released the study
that um basically said 87 of classic
games released in the US are now an
endangered species I did love that
wording yeah endangered but yeah and
that is pretty much because they are
entirely out of print at this point yeah
so at the top of this episode I wanted
to say huge shout out to the video game
history foundation for all the
incredible work they do also shout out
to Gerard Khalil aka the completionist
who brought this to my attention when I
was talking to him on Monday he also
made a fantastic video over on his
channel so we're talking about it
because as well it's something that is
way more prevalent in the world of our
modern media because
at the at the the blink of an eye the
snap of her finger your media could go
away just like that it's it's the not
even the hidden or the it's the it's the
thing about digital proliferation of
content that we kind of turn a blind eye
to everything is digital but it also
means that a couple of button presses
and a couple of clicks or or you know a
server being unplugged it could be the
end of something that you care about or
just even even something that you don't
care about but has historical value yeah
sometimes you need to see the mistakes
that were made sometimes you there's
content that might not be amazing but
there's value in knowing that it was
there and these days it's easier to just
make things go away than ever before
because we no longer have the physical
media at least Back Then There Were ways
to do it and it became more arduous as
we went along but there was options
these days lesser yeah I was gonna say
looking at you know what Disney is doing
what HBO and Warner Brothers is doing
you know taking whole TV shows putting
it on their streaming services and then
just wiping them and there are some
really heartbreaking tweets you can find
of people who have worked on shows and
it's like oh well cool our show just
finished they've canceled it and now
they've wiped it from existence yeah so
that's two years of my life gone we are
talking today about video games some key
takeaways from the study you should go
read it um they've done it in a very
digestible way to kind of get the key
takeaways but they've also put up a
giant methodology of how they found out
it's like 40 pages long
um but basically since 2012 museums
libraries and archivists have been
petitioning the US copyright office for
new exemptions that would make archiving
video games much easier and then the
founding of this study was basically
that 13 only 13 of classic games are
actually readily available or still in
print
um which is better than uh the
availability of pre-World War II audio
recordings but worse than the survival
rate of American silent films so that's
where we're currently sitting yeah and
the end to the other part of this is
opposition yeah the esa the esa
God just absolutely taken else left
right in the center like the esa needs
to just take a moment you know so the
esa is basically the reason why they're
getting involved is because they are
basically the official lobbying uh
entity for video games when it comes to
this kind of stuff and they have argued
successfully over the years that video
game companies are doing more than
enough in making these video games
commercially available so that
archivists and you know museums and
libraries don't need to get involved
because the commercial side of the video
games industry is tackling this so they
can say oh well we've put all of these
PS2 games on PS plus and that's fine but
then if you think about it this is also
another great shitty argument so they
actually call this out in the study
because before they wipe the eShop uh
there was something like 11 of Game Boy
games a Game Boy family games are
available they wiped the eShop and that
figure has now gone down to like five
point something percent the other thing
is like let's say for argument's sake
that the video game industry is grabbing
a chunk of this stuff and putting it up
they're doing it in a way that is
beneficial to themselves and not to the
preservation part of it there's no
guarantee that the thing that they're
gonna put out is gonna perform in the
same way that the original should I feel
like the people who spend the time and
effort figuring the those things out and
preserving it they do it with as much
thought put into the context around it
and how people experienced it then and
how they can replicate that experience
again there's a decent chance that when
a video game company takes this and
re-pushes it out they change it in some
way which is I mean there is um if you
read the study there is a bunch of stuff
about like how do we decide what remains
in print or not because you know like
Yakuza kiwami yeah very different to the
original you know but it's still a sense
to be the same game just been modernized
there are games that just aren't
available anymore anyway because of
Licensing issues so if you look at old
movie tie-in games can't buy any they'll
Lord of the Rings stuff anymore and even
when stuff gets remade and remastered
changes are made look at I mean there
are a lot of things going on with the
GTA Definitive Edition but one of the
things that they had to change was the
soundtrack which is the one of the most
iconic parts of it and it's not just as
simple as oh they just ripped out a
couple of songs and it's fine no there's
a specific mood and kind of like
Nostalgia to the specific songs that are
there that is reflective of the time
when it was released and we played it so
the the version of GTA
um Vice City for example that people
play now is fundamentally different
because the songs have been changed or
new things have been added or modernized
and removed and let's say from an
academic perspective you want to look at
the evolution of games having that
version of the new version of GTA Vice
City while taking the original off steam
or making the original unavailable is is
changing history like it is being it is
causing inaccuracies and I don't think
like that is fair for our own medium
like I don't understand this kind of
like absolute disregard for and respect
for our own medium and preserving it now
this is something that we should all as
people who love video games kind of come
together and say like we want the legacy
of this industry to be properly
represented because look how far we've
come look at the amazing things we've
achieved what are the options for people
who want to go back it's a pirate's life
for me pirate's life or you know
investing in if you don't have your
original consoles it's like hunting down
going through the classic games retro
games Market you know I go on eBay or go
on Amazon or Facebook Marketplace and
buy an old console and hope that someone
has yeah a copy of the exact game that I
wanted to play and it also kind of like
snowballs like you buy that old console
let's say you pick up a PlayStation one
and you want to have the most authentic
experience either by the old console
then you probably need a CRT TV you need
XYZ it is pushing people to piracy and
like fundamentally we the double-edged
sort of is like piracy obviously hurts
the industry when it when it is like
things that are actively you know
available now and new things and I don't
like seeing that happen because it takes
money out of like developers Pockets but
if you give us no choice but to take the
old stuff and pirate it
that's what I like I can't tell people
not to do that because like I can't go
out and buy metal gear acid I want to
play Metal Gear acid I have to hunt that
thing down why isn't it available no
one's buying it no one's selling it it's
not preserved anyway in any meaningful
way I mean it is but we all know how to
get it we have to hit up some websites
that give you a lot of pop-ups and
like if that's the only way you're going
to do it if I can do it now all right
the other reason why we're talking about
this is because there are places you
know the internet archive uh video game
history Foundation who are determined
and like I mean Daniel Dwyer former
games one current no clip is going
through this incredible process right
now where he's digitizing all these old
tapes for preservation purposes so that
people can continue to enjoy them
because a lot of them were sat in boxing
hour oh it was awesome
no and so you have these places like
archive.org yeah it's currently being
sued
um and so yeah seriously read up on that
because it's corporations trying to
increase the erase uh large chunks of
online history so if you can support
please do support archive.org it is more
like important than you may realize
remember how people reacted around PT
yeah every game is about to be a PT yeah
pretty much like and that is that is it
sounds hyperbolic but honestly I mean
It's All Digital I mean like
I I'm part of the problem I'm basically
more digital now yeah
um it's hard not to be it's convenient
um it doesn't take up space in my
apartment but at the same time if I
wanted to go back and look for an
original PS2 copy of Okami
that shouldn't be this difficult for me
to do it a few years from now we're not
going to be able to experience the games
that are coming out today because the
practice now is you have half the game
on the disc and the rest is downloaded
yep like so you can't even download not
even buying the physical version of the
game is a good guarantee that you will
be able to play this game in the future
because there's significant chunks of
those games that are just on servers and
you need to be able to download them so
like I don't understand why there's such
a kind of contempt for
um preservation around games and I think
like I said we should be way more
focused on this stuff so video game
preservation should be the top of every
Gamer's mind uh we're gonna keep
reporting on this and looking into it
and kind of calling out things as they
move along but yeah let us know what you
think uh go support the video game
history Foundation go support
archive.org gospel draw in this video
and Danny and all of his uh digitizing
efforts and anyone else you see like
making the moves to uh bully some
Publishers just bully them just go on
there and be like why aren't you
preserving this game ABS I give you
permission slightly
enough is enough bully these fours
not bad my bad I'll take that back I
forgot crap in my mind I've just got
people like tweeting at Bobby kotech
being like you suck man make this
available again kindly requested things
kindly requested from Community managers
and PR people
take on on road tell him to give you
this stuff you know give him the
business there's a lot of things you
guys anyway thank you everyone for
watching this two weeks episode spot on
we are not going to be doing an episode
next week we're not we're at Comic-Con
oh so if you want to try and Slot that
into our schedule I'm good but we'll be
back the week after
um let us know what you think about the
preservation stuff we talked about today
if there are any other cool resources
you think we should check out put them
in the comments you can find me on
Twitter at Lucy James games I'm atomore
H we'll see you next time
I did it again three fingers